but we start this newshour with breaking
news out of burkina faso where one of
the biggest massacres in years has been
committed
armed men have killed around a hundred
civilians in the northern part of the
country
the attack happened in the village of
salhan close to niger
the government says that homes at a
market were burned to the ground
it's the first such attack on this scale
since 2015.
al jazeera's nicholas hack is monitoring
those developments uh from
bamako and neighboring mali nick what
more do we know
about what happened
[Music]
well it was in the early hours of this
morning adrian that
a police patrol were driving through a
market like this one
except instead of seeing animals and
people sitting around what they
discovered
was hundreds of bodies laying around
women children men at least 100 people
officially are dead but there could be
more they saw some of the survivors and
in the market where the animals were
kept well that was completely burnt to
the ground
the huts were also burned to the ground
this is adrian the worst attack in
burkina faso since 2015 when
we started to see attacks claimed by
the armed group the islamic state in the
greater sahara and in fact adrian
while no one has claimed responsibility
for this attack there has been
in the in the eastern part of burkina
faso
next to this village other attacks just
a couple of days ago
adrian there was five boys that were
had their hands chopped off what they're
trying to do here
adrian is to signal to the population
that they are the one
in charge of law and order and despite
the brutality of this attack
with their aim is to say they need to
they need to answer to them rather than
the state now there was
a military camp not far from where the
attack took place
but they didn't respond adrian the
violence isn't limited though to burkina
faso
is it that whole area uh taking in
burkina faso niger
mali where you are right now uh the
security situation
is dire what's being done about it
well just early on we were talking to
the representative of the
norwegian refugee council and he was
just saying that the situation is
getting from bad
to worse and what is this what this is
showing is that despite
the heavy security and military presence
in the region
while that is not helping ordinary
people from burkina faso to mali where
i'm standing right now
are people that have been displaced from
the north and the center of the country
these are people that were displaced
just a couple of months ago because
over there there are there is communal
violence between
um fulani herders and dogon
dogon villagers and in the absence of
the state
well armed groups have found a way to
come in and replace
state authorities and they're trying to
recruit
young herders from because
follow in the absence of of the state
one
point what more than one million people
have been displaced in burkina faso
alone a hundred thousand people have
been displaced in mali alone in the last
year
adrian these are staggering numbers and
despite
the u.n presence the sahel the french
forces that are
patrolling and deploy throughout the
sahel the situation is getting worse and
those that are suffering
are the people that are living in this
region whether they are in burkina faso
mali or niger adrian al jazeera's
nicholas hack reporting live there from
balako in mali for the moment uh
nick many thanks indeed